Chiefs Eagles what are we thinking
I hate to say this man the guy Patrick
Mahomes I did not think he would recover
as quick as he did he played a good game
against the bank injury looked a little
wild it's a high ankle sprain which
normally he's like something that's a
Liz Frank no that's a different thing
what I got why can't we've recovered I
like magic
the same guy yeah a high ankle sprained
usually like six to eight weeks super
like it just eats away like just it's a
nagging injury yeah but he played pretty
well against the Chiefs and they I'm the
Bengals and they won they got a couple
of calls that were dicey but they won he
played well yeah if he recovers maybe
they could beat the Eagles but if he's
not fully recovered then I don't think
they beat the Eagles I hate saying that
based on how he played though based on
how he played he wouldn't beat the
Eagles he needs to be more healed than
that he still had a good game yeah but
the eagle you know they say Styles make
fights for boxing yeah same for every
sport basically yeah but in football if
you have a really good defensive line
that can [__] up any quarterback that's
why Brady lost to the Giants and the
Eagles that defensive line was crazy
legitimately it's one of the best ever
the Eagles defensively they remind me of
the [__] Giants remember the Giants
back in the day when they were just rush
three dudes when the Giants won their uh
yeah they're Super Bowl four Dudes but
they wouldn't Blitz they don't need a
blitz these four are gonna get and then
we'll hang everybody back in cover yeah
and the Eagles have and they have a
really good offensive line so Jalen
Hart's gonna have all kinds of time he's
not he's a good quarterback he's not as
good as him Holmes but if you give him
time and Mahomes doesn't have time
impress me bro composure the guy's a
[__] hero man he's just got like a
great mentality and I hate giving the
Eagles credit my wife was literally
singing the [__] Eagles stupid fight
song on the couch in my face as they're
winning no I think at a certain point in
time we just gonna need to just give it
up for Philadelphia like it was cool to
maybe hate on the fans and call them you
know trash and calling these things
they're the most dedicated supportive in
love with their team fans and every
sport and every single Sport and they do
have successes not like the eagles
haven't had success no they've been very
good and they still ride like they
haven't won a single Championship yeah I
thought the first Super Bowl would calm
them down it did not crazier not at all
yeah yeah they ride for every sport and
the eagles they [__] ride for oh they
deserve it best friends they don't
deserve best fans in sports it's good
that they get the respect and I like
that New Yorkers respecting them too you
know by like bending over and making the
Empire State Building yo yo yo son that
was that's embarrassing
for y'all I think it's cool
you said that you need to give it up for
the fans and I agree I'm glad we gave it
up oh wow I'm glad your whole city game
like it was Miles dude
God damn mom
come on back it up
for three years
he goes up to this girl he goes up to
this girl for some European ass girl and
he goes he goes hey my name is miles or
as you would say kilometers
[Music]
let's say I'm kilometers to you no no I
don't know what I did that night but if
it was that lame yeah with a fat ass and
then he put on Juvenile Back That Ass Up
son so that I like that Jesus who do you
think's gonna win the Super Bowl okay
listen I don't know I mean you were
saying something [__] up about no I
was saying we need to show respect to
Philly just like you in the whole city
that was embarrassing we did listen but
New York is a global city is a little
different than where you guys are from
but look obviously you guys you know
support your own little local things
yeah New York is a global city so we
acknowledge everything in the globe yeah
it's not the happiest place on Earth but
it's it's not the happiest place on
Earth it's not Dallas whatever y'all are
known for yeah yeah okay but it's New
York and we have to acknowledge the
happenings of the world we have to do
that now was it dumb yes on New Yorkers
upset about it yes it was stupid it's
probably some [__] from outside
New York no it's not like the Empire
State building's like the most iconic
building in New York you know what I
mean it's just it's not like it like you
think in New York and you think of the
Empire State Building no it's not like
that you know what I mean I don't know
Empire stable is just a building nobody
ever cares about it they don't identify
with it I'm too triggered to understand
yeah I don't know if he's doing if this
is I don't know yeah like I'm saying no
one cares about this so it doesn't
matter if they have Eagles colors
seven days before eight days before it
is fine don't worry about it cowboys bro
yeah yeah oh they're terrible
they're as good as the Giants they're
terrible